ben on retient de l'homme enfin moi je
retiendrai de l'homme son
professionnalisme mon rapport avec lui
je le connais depuis son enfance
et puis je les rencontre alors qu'il
était jeune pigiste avec jean-claude gym
et mais il a cité en exemple vous voulez
parler à neymar aujourd'hui vous appelez
camille il connaît pas mais il n'a pas
le meilleur élément méconnu quelques
mots et quelques jeunes et quelques il
avait une mémoire extraordinaire alors
c'est là vont s'accrocher un petit peu
au tour des yoles parce que ça mais moi
les hommes les tableaux équivalente à la
mienne mais camille il va beaucoup nous
manquer sur le tour d'ailleurs autour
des yeux ne sera plus pareil
c'était une encyclopédie du sport
c'était une encyclopédie du sport il
avait sa tablette parce qu'ils étaient
nous sommes dans un monde moderne
mais la baisse son petit carnet qu'avec
des numéros dans tous les sens je ne
sais d'ailleurs pas comment s'y
retrouver dans cette affaire-là
mais c'était vraiment c'est un grand
professionnel à l'ehpad allemand le dk
milliards de ces petits machins qui nous
ont tous s'amuser c'était un
professionnel c'est ce que je retiens de
lui